Allora Martin barlic salta perché
l'abbiamo già fatto l'anno scorso Io
farei chiesto Kevin Harris eh David
Guetta e comunque quest'anno mo
facciamocelo locale o no Ma che capito
una cara una spiaggia sai non cala Basta
che la salata quelle robe lì ogni volta
torniamo Più bianca di aprire
un sogno non svegliatemi Madonna che
piange
[Musica]
Guardala amo fammi una foto Fammi venire
che la metto come fotografia e là
prendi anche dietro che c'è scritto
fuori Prendi prendi tutto io La mia amo
Siamo all'Arena della iza baci
abbracciali invidiosis che ci Guardate
sempre la vostra invidia la nostra forza
Oh ma quello spagnolo che ci ha provato
tutta rosa oro Aspetta che lo chiamo
Ciao sono la chica italiana di Eris Ah
senti Ma che fai Ah Cala Conte Minchia
se ci vengo a Cala Conte Ma se vengo
anche la Conte possa essere un po' sola
con te non capire mica appena ti prendo
Vedi c'è niente da fare Ibiza ti entra
proprio dentro ogni volta lasciarlo a un
colpo